- Hello, everyone, so
welcome to another episode
of Unlocking Lily.
It's always been my dream to be a speaker
and with the help of Evan,
I'm able to do this full-time
and you guys are all coming
along for the ride with me.
(air whooshing)
(impact echoing)
So, Evan challenged me
to research 20 speakers
and the reason for that is,
I'm starting out on my journey
and the truth is, I can figure
everything out on my own,
but it will take me a
very, very long time.
So, to shorten that process,
it's important for me
to take a look at all the people
who have done similar
things to what I want to do
and I could look at their path,
so, that way, I can could
fast-track my process
and then model after them.
So, I needed 20 speakers.
I only had three, three people
that I've been following
for the past few years,
but I needed 17 more.
How do I do that, right?
And so, I thought to myself,
"Well, you know what?
"Evan actually covers a
lot of successful people
"on his channel, I'm sure
some of them are speakers,"
and it's true.
I did find a lot of them on his channel,
but I needed more than that
and, Google being our best friend,
I actually Googled famous speakers
and I was able to come up
with my list of 20 names.
And, once I got the 20 names,
I split the research into two parts,
so I had one part which
was a path to success
and the other part is their business side.
So, the path to success is very crucial.
The reason for that is,
right now, I'm just starting,
so for me to compare my
beginning to their top,
is what they're doing right now, seems
like it's way too much of a leap
and it almost seems impossible, at times.
But, if I were to actually
look at all the things
that they have done in
their previous years
and when they first got started, it may,
not only does it make it
more realistic for me,
but it also makes more sense.
Now, okay, these are the
things that I need to do
to get to where they are today.
And, on the business
side, I want to be able
to make an income from speaking,
so for me to look at all the things
that they are doing to earn an
income, it's going to help me
create a business around
speaking, as well.
So, as part of my research,
I needed to highlight their breakthroughs.
So, what are the specific
things that they did
to break them through into
the successes they are today?
And, as I was doing my
research, I started to realize
that there were three common ways
that they were breaking through.
So, the first one is
(chimes ringing)
to find a king maker,
so what that means is
to leverage an existing brand or media.
So, for example, Oprah
Winfrey and Les Brown were,
had mediocre success,
but they didn't actually
become household names
until they had their own talk shows.
And, even Jack Canfield,
who used to be an educator,
and he didn't actually become
known for what he is today
until he published his first book in his
Chicken Soup for the Soul series.
Number two is to grind out content.
It's to work consistently on your craft,
day after day after day.
So, you have Neil Pasricha,
who wrote on his blog, 1000
Awesome Things, every single day
until, one day, he was recognized
and he was able to get
a book deal out of it,
which is The Book of Awesome,
and Eric Thomas, who
put out YouTube videos
after YouTube videos after YouTube videos,
until one of them went viral
and had over 40 million views.
And, number three is to prove it live.
These are the folks that went onstage
and actually proved
themselves and their message
and stood up for what they believed in.
So, you have Tony Robbins
who was well-known,
but did not become notorious
until he went onstage
and cured a woman from her snake phobia
after being challenged by a
psychiatrist that he was a fake,
and even Brene Brown and Simon Sinek
who were relatively unknown
before they had their
world-popular TEDx talks,
which actually put them on the map
as being the leading thought leaders.
So, on the business side,
I was able to identify
three common ways they
were making an income,
so number one, are
online training programs.
So, Shawn Achor, Gabrielle
Bernstein and Zig Ziglar
all have online courses
that they sell through their website.
Number two are books.
Lisa Nichols, Robin
Sharma and Dale Carnegie
all wrote best-sellers that
sold millions of copies.
Number three are live events and seminars.
Tony Robbins, Brendon
Burchard and Eckhart Tolle
all sell out their shows months leading up
to their live events.
So, I walked into this research
knowing I wanted to be a speaker,
but I'm walking away with
so much more clarity.
On the breakthrough side,
I love the people that proved it live.
There's something so magical
and exhilarating to me about going onstage
and showing yourself,
showing up as yourself
and standing up for what you believe in
and proving yourself and
proving your message.
So, I really want to focus
my energy into doing that.
And, on the business
side, I love coaching.
I loved the one-on-one connection
that I get with people,
not only that, to see them being inspired
by their own awesomeness
and going out there
and doing amazing things
and taking action.
So, I'm going to focus a lot
of my energy into coaching
and, as much as I love
the one-on-one connection
that I get from coaching,
I love a group environment, as well.
There's something so fulfilling to me
when I see a group of
people support each other
and have empathy for each other
and then walk away as a
group feeling, you know,
completely inspired and ready
to, like, take on their goals,
it's such an amazing feeling.
So, on the business side,
I'm going to really focus
a lot of my time into the
coaching and the workshop side.
So, this research gave me so much more
than just a path to becoming a speaker.
It gave me confidence.
A lot of the times, I think to myself
that maybe my goal is too bold,
maybe I can't get there,
maybe it's a silly idea.
You know, what makes me think
that I could actually achieve
the same amount of success
as all these people did?
You know, maybe I should have started
when I was a lot younger.
I don't have a lot of time.
I need more education.
I need to go back to school.
I need to go get a PhD.
Until that happens,
I can't actually go
onstage and give a speech
because I don't know
what I'm talking about,
or I feel like I don't have the money
to back up this business plan that I have.
And, the truth is, a lot of
these people that I researched
started off with a lot less
than what I have right now.
I already have way more.
You know, look at Dale Carnegie.
He was actually homeless
when he started off his first seminar,
he was living at the YMCA,
and the things that he's accomplished,
from having so little, is incredible.
Even years and years after his passing,
people know his training programs.
They know his books.
His books are still one of
the best-sellers in the world.
So, what gives me the excuse?
But, at the same time, it
makes me feel very confident.
If he can do it, so can I
and that's really the truth, right?
Anything that you want
to do is not too bold
because people who have done it before you
have done it with a lot less.
So, for my next challenge,
I'm going to take you guys
on a deeper journey into the three people
that I resonated with the most,
so they are Tony Robbins,
Brene Brown and Simon Sinek.
I'm going to share with you
what are the specific things that they did
to get to where they are today.
And, also, what are the things
that I have learned from them
that I can put into action right away?
So, the question of the day is,
who are the three people
that you look up to
in your industry that you're
going to start researching today?
I love reading your comments
and I would love to find out who they are,
so leave in the comments below
and I'm going to join
in on the discussion.
So, thank you so much for watching,
but, more importantly, I am
so grateful for having you
on this journey with me.
You have been so
supportive and encouraging
and loving since day one
and, honestly, I couldn't have asked
for a better community than Believe Nation
to be part of this crazy ride that I'm on.
And, I actually have a special
shout out for Karthik Reddy,
so Karthik wrote,
"Lily, you improved
Lily, congratulations."
So, Karthik, thank you so much
for writing the encouraging kind words.
It really does mean a lot to me,
so thank you and thank you guys
and I'll see you very, very soon
for another episode of Unlocking Lily.
Thank you and I love you all (smooching).
(air whooshing)
(impact echoing)